hi this is lucien rob from gamespot
hello and we have been playing the brand
new mario kart 8 dlc this is the second
DLC pack which adds a brand new top
speed so the previous top speed which is
150 you can see on the left-hand side of
the screen the brand new one is 200 and
Rob what did you think of the of the
leaf art well the leap between hundred
50cc and 200 cc is quite vast is now I
think it straddles the line between
super fast and dangerously fast I think
we were crashing into corners quite
often we were playing it yes so we've
done this video visa this is what the
new speed is kind of like on some of the
old favourite track so here we've got
toads turnpike and you can really just
see how far ahead you can zip ahead when
you're playing as 200 seeds so far
behind hundred and fifty years yeah I
mean that the leap is quite phenomenal
and we should point out this DLC is
actually free isn't it so you can get
the the new the two new cups and the
three new characters if you buy the dlc
and a yes this top speed is coming for
free and I really hate to use the phrase
it is a bit of a game changer just
because it does make it feel even more
frantic and frenetic than before but the
thing is is that you played all the
original merica eight tracks and you
familiarize yourself of how they work
with this new speed I it's so difficult
to kind of get your way round under the
new speed like we had to press the brake
but yeah you just seen it here on the
the 200 there you had to actually break
and the awkward thing was neither of us
knew where the quick one was and we both
had to ask for it individually when we
were playing needs to be done right it's
been yeah B is for break I just
beautiful uh so in this video you get to
see I've added it in such a way that the
next time both in come on screen so on
the right 200cc is gonna finish this is
how far behind 150 years it's crazy and
I came we came first in both of these
yeah that's right um when you jump off
from saat sonra cc'd like we're about to
see here I think yep well the feeling is
actually amazing it's just so if you
land it properly yeah like hundred fifty
is like a lap behind ok so this course
is Mount warrior this is a what nearly
gave me you as well either stress
attack you know so i can understand that
because you're basically going downhill
on ice at 200 cc now how did that feel
these well you can just see I've just
bang into everything uh do not hundred
VDC oh yeah true i mean this is me
playing is Yoshi watch me I'm gonna bang
into the side here probably but yeah I
mean yeah there we go um it's a it's
it's so frantic and the thing is like
you feel both at the same time like you
have way less control but when you do
things like this and like really leap
over things you feel more empowered yeah
yeah this isn't a mixture of
exhilaration and total fear so done I'm
ready to this one so this is how far
ahead 150cc is has to be in order to
finish at the same time whoa 200 well
thats quiet head start I just went over
a bump and it didn't really slow me down
that much so it's so it's great it's
fast I love it and for more on Mario
Kart 8 make sure you keep your eye on
gamespot